what's going on everybody gets warned
and welcome back to cosmic wonder where
we talk about everything marvel today
tons of new spider-man 3 info including
the working title for the film comments
from Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige himself some Norman Osborn news
and of course we have to talk about that
now very real possibility that we could
be getting a live-action spider-verse
spider-man in the MCU gave us quite the
scare last year but now he is back in
the MCU where he belongs and spider-man
3 is coming out on July 16th of 2021 and
things are moving at an extremely fast
pace now for the movie so I'll break
down everything that you need to know be
sure to subscribe and hit the bell to
stay up to date on spider-man and the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4
picking a winner at 550,000 subscribers
so to start off with the first out of
all of the awesome news that we got for
spider-man 3 is the running title
several days ago it was revealed that
the running title for spider-man 3 is
serenity now and this is good news and
very appropriate for the third
spider-man film in the MCU for a few
reasons
one is that we get this working title
ahead of production so that means things
are moving along quite nicely for
spider-man 3 the second is that it is a
very clear reference to the 90s sitcom
Seinfeld in the series serenity now is a
mantra that is used to calm the person
saying at however it's revealed to have
the alternate effect in the long run in
the series and the third reason is that
spider-man 3 having the working title of
serenity now means that they are keeping
with the spider-man tradition and what I
mean by that is the first two spider-man
MCU films also got running titles that
were named from Seinfeld
spider-man homecoming in 2017 s working
title was summer of George a title very
clearly derived from Seinfeld and then
again in 2019 with spider-man far from
home the movie was shot under the name
fall of George so they're sticking with
their classic tradition by having the
running title for spider-man 3 be
serenity now now there's a lot that's
been happening recently with the
development of spider-man 3 everything
is in pre-production right now but there
have been a lot of meetings with the
studio and Tom
Hollan about the film so things are very
well underway in fact Tom Holland has
recently revealed that he is met with
Marvel Studios and talked to Sony of
course about the film and about their
future plans for spider-man in the MCU
and he said that he met with Marvel and
Sony and now he knows everything
so Tom Holland has officially been told
everything that is going on with
spider-man and everything that is going
to happen with him in the future so
hopefully he pulls a classic Tom and
spills the beans soon but Kevin Feige
has also recently opened up about what
to expect in the next spider-man film of
the franchise now in the past after the
spider-man Disney Sony deal came to a
completion Kevin Feige opened up and
told us a little bit about what to
expect and he said far from home sets up
a Peter Parker story that has never been
done before on film and he implied that
this film is not only going to be
different than anything we've seen
before but also bigger and recently he
opened up again about what we can expect
he said Spidey will be in his element
out of the shadow of Tony and the
Avengers as his own man and hero now so
in spider-man 3 we're really going to
see Peter Parker shine as his own person
and spider-man homecoming he was
definitely under the wing of Tony Stark
and the same goes for infinity war and
Avengers end game and then again in
spider-man far from home Tony's presence
was definitely felt all throughout the
movie and then of course he had Mysterio
who he thought was going to be a mentor
for him but of course we know how that
turned out and then he had happy happy
was there to take care of him he was
there with the jet to make his new
spider-man suit he was there with the
pep talk
happy gave him the motivation that he
needed to go and defeat Mysterio but now
according to Kevin Feige he's not going
to have any of that in the next film and
if we think about how spider-man far
from home left off in the post-credits
scene it makes a lot of sense Peter
Parker's identity is revealed everybody
knows that he is spider-man and
everybody thinks that he's a murderer
everyone thinks he killed Mysterio so
he's going to be on the run and he
probably won't be able to contact most
of the people that he knows and loves so
it seems like this next film is really
going to be about just spider-man just
Peter Parker all about him and how we
can step up on his own and become a hero
and this is coming to
directly from Kevin Feige so we can't
expect this but what can we expect as
far as the villain is concerned well of
course we know about Kraven the hunter
and the possibility of the sinister six
however recently we've heard a rumor
about Norman Osborn
now before spider-man far from home came
out there were some people that said
they saw a pre-screening of far from
home and in the post-credits scene they
showed Norman Osborn in this post-credit
scene we saw Norman Osborn assembling
the sinister six now this was not of
course in the final cut of the movie but
some people who saw it like Grace
Randolph claimed that this is indeed
what they did see and now it appears
that we have somebody on reddit who says
that they know what happened and what is
going to happen with Norman Osborn so of
course this was posted anonymously and
it says so before I tell you about what
Marvel's current plan for Osborn is let
me tell you what their plan was so
before spider-man fire from home
released Marvel had a huge plan for
Norman Osborn in the MCU with him being
one of the main antagonists in fact in
the original script there was a
post-credits scene that featured him
however in the months leading up to the
film's release talks between Marvel and
Sony turned bitter and they decided to
put their plans for Osborn on the
backburner because they could lose his
rights at any second now this very well
could have happened we don't really know
the ins and outs of what really happened
between Sony and Disney we have our
speculation and we've heard rumors but
we don't know 100% but it does make
sense that if Marvel and Disney didn't
know if they were going to have
spider-man in the MCU in the future they
wouldn't want to introduce Norman Osborn
because then nothing would happen and
we'd have a dead end with that story
so if plans really did fall through
right before spider-man far from home
got released and they were planning to
introduce Norman Osborn it would make
sense that Marvel and Disney decided to
delay their introduction of Norman
Osborn but they go on to say now that
Marvel and Sony have a new deal however
Marvel has a new plan for Osborn the
current plan is to make him a shadow
villain much like Palpatine from Star
Wars or Voldemort from Harry Potter and
they plan to make him this in spider-man
3 so this is kind of going to be like
ant-man and the wasp we heard there is a
benefactor but we never learned who it
was
and it could be Osborne if that's
Marvel's plans but this will set up
Norman Osborn for a much bigger role in
the MCU Osborn like spider-man and Jay
jonah Jameson will also have some
appearances in Sony's Marvel Universe
and will be a part of the connective
glue that unites the two film universes
however Sony themselves don't have big
plans for the character and he'll mainly
be a part of the mainline MCU Marvel
does have plans for the Dark Avengers
but not until at least much later in
phase 5 and for those of you who are not
aware Norman Osborn and the comics is
the leader of the Dark Avengers now this
of course is in no way a confirmation
that any of this will happen but things
have lined up and people have claimed to
have seen a post-credits scene with
Norman Osborn and it does seem like the
MCU is going the route of setting up a
Dark Avengers which Norman Osborn is the
leader of and not to mention he is a
major spider-man character and hopefully
spider-man has a long feature in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
and speaking of spider-man's feature in
the MCU we have some big news that could
really affect future spider-man films it
is official now that Sam Raimi the
director of the original Tobey Maguire
spider-man trilogy is on board to direct
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness and this was confirmed by a
report from The Hollywood Reporter in
which they said in a bit of moviemaking
irony Sam Raimi was at one time attached
to direct Bermuda Raimi recently signed
on to helm Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness after derrickson
exited that film earlier this year
Bermuda centered around the Bermuda
Triangle had a script from Doug Moreau
and Carlo Bernard when Raimi was
attached derrickson and his writing
partner see Robert Cargill will rewrite
the script and this is really big news
because there has been a lot of talk
recently that Marvel and Sony could be
making a live-action spider-verse film
the spider-man into the spider-verse
film had massive success and fans
absolutely want a live-action version
and Sam Raimi could be the perfect
person to do that starting with a cameo
from Tobey Maguire spider-man the
spider-man from the trilogy that he
directed having a cameo in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
it's the perfect opportunity because we
do know that the film
is going to explore the multiverse
ultimate realities and alternate
timelines created from Avengers endgame
and of course we all remember the Doctor
Strange Easter egg that Sam Raimi threw
in spider-man 2 Doctor Strange that's
pretty good it's taken Sam Raimi
literally dropped a Doctor Strange
easter egg before the MCU was even a
thing this was before all of the films
were even connected and before the
marvel cinematic universe existed but he
teased the connection years and years
ago and now he is the director of the
film that is going to be exploring
alternate realities and he could be the
person that Marvel and Sony choose to
direct a live-action spider-verse film
and also not to mention Sony and Marvel
recently announced a movie that the two
of them are producing coming out in
October of 2021 now recently Marvel and
Disney have removed themselves from this
movie but it's widely believed to be a
Spider Woman movie so we have spider-man
Spider Woman that could possibly exist
in an alternate universe because it's
not going to be attached to Marvel and a
very likely cameo from Tobey Maguire
spider-man and Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness thanks to Sam
Raimi now directing it does appear that
everything seems to be in place if
Marvel and Sony wanted to go down the
route of a live-action spider-verse
and again there have been some reports
of it but of course nothing is
officially confirmed until the studio's
announced it but in the meantime we get
to look forward to spider-man 3 so let
me know how excited you are about all of
the future possibilities with spider-man
drop a comment down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe but
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof